So if this is our population. Where the y-axis is frequency. And the x-axis is
the engagement ratio. We know that if we picked every possible sample of size 20
from this distribution and then we calculated the mean of each sample and then
plotted the distribution of means. It will be normal. The mean of this
distribution should be the population mean, which you calculated to be 77
1000ths. And the standard deviation of this distribution is the population
standard deviation divided by the sample size, which is 0.107 divided by the
square root of 20. And if we round to the nearest thousandth, we get 24 1000ths.
So this is a standard error. When we found that, that the mean engagement ratio
of our sample of size 20 was 0.13, we can compare it on this distribution, in
terms of standard error. We want to know how many standard errors 0.13 is from
the mean.